welcome to this video playing jammie
Dodger from the UK it's been a while
that i'm at a plate and i only have
fifty percent like six wins six losses
one draw okay i'm playing playing this
slightly slightly dull line i want i
want an easy life here for a moment no
no weird king's indian complications
another exchanges it's not a bad line
it's just it's just slightly am slightly
dull okay um this is uncommon really see
five I wonder is there for a good move
likessee for Bishop hmm hmm then maybe a
six hmm but if I go to d1 isn't this
good before Bishop you too yeah the sun
is probably good young
Bishop a 692 is just it's just good for
what isn't it 92 c 3 tags tags
yeah okay it's good for white but i
could not sure how exactly i should play
this hmm castling here on a 5 rook a
form might also be possible
hmm it's not so clear how I actually
develop stuff him
hmm how do I develop here you have a
night on T 2 hmm yeah I should have
thought about that for a moment and
probably some other move order was
better trying to activate the rook on
age three it's clear that it is not also
not easy for black because 97 for
example I can be answered with B 3 and
then a 6 hangs so it's not not totally
easy for for him to play but ok I'm
clearly overestimated my position at
first him now probably be shipped it'll
probably i played this too quickly the
special this 90 to 1 set up my bishop on
c1 especially is the problem
I'm not seeing anything totally
brilliant for him mmm this one okay okay
maybe a [ __ ] 3i he wants to break this
up okay while h5 is anyway opening the H
file they are not like for our checkmate
this is not a Sicilian dragon but I want
to activate the rook use it don't it
make sense to push push why ok so I'm
maybe be able to play the three first I
can take that sets clear and now I can
also take a five and play look f LH 5 or
again b3 simply be three Knight b6 yeah
I can take that anyway yeah okay I need
to need to play
okay so i can i can take here or then
what is the big big problem takes on I
don't know I take here first how to how
to evaluate anyway mmm yeah this I
didn't think about is taking on on d 2
with a check hmm that's let's of course
not good
hmm yeah this is somehow losing pretty
sure not sure how exactly but I'm pretty
sure it is losing okay the bishop has no
scram and I'm not one hundred percent
sure how bad this is I can play rook age
five fear or time morning yeah yeah I
know he wants to take d5 quite that's
clear
takes I play rook g5 patient b3 this c3
I don't know like the so can look at
somewhat see to map see to Roxy one
mmm yeah probably lost but reform maybe
Mary carry me I can fight a bit yeah
this wasn't really greater maybe I can
get this pawn only 5 22 seconds so this
is really a really a problem I mean the
position probably also is but check I
don't don't see yet how I'm Jana this
isn't this ok now I mean I'm threatening
all kinds of stuff on g7 and NC three
you cannot move the porn I just take
take the rock
yeah okay what just was winning no but
I've got six seconds dra heart yeah no
one is talking about a draw no matter
how the position is of course black I
never never ever win him white forfeits
halftime yeah of course only way to win
yeah I don't know i mean probably i was
i was losing at some point anyway but
him simply never hidden he didn't put it
away until he was completely lost and
then I spoiled it again with no time on
the clock gym around here just it's
probably just losing with the right
moves f four wins for like hour yeah
there must be someone see three sm is
clearly a big problem now Geum eat diet
becomes becomes to be problematic for
black he knows just keep giving away all
old stuff em check check not your white
is just totally winning look a one is
the move that wins IAM brooke a one-eyed
push the ape on it promotes but ok i had
12 seconds i was content with securing
this this winning position but ok six
seconds it's um no way junk tuned to
channel to manage that I'd like to check
the opening again because while c5 is
just a bad move but I didn't refute it
so a four is Right see for this should
be one be form ok up to here it's it's
ok that's
okay but i have i've made some mistake
here with the 92 clearly because it
totally clocks up my pieces i came it
seems that bishop d2 is right attacking
the b4 porn here and rooks you on yeah
this is the type of setup that I need
we're all pieces play and ce4 it's just
the weakness it's difficult for him now
to even try to keep it if he tries that
II five hangs as well now 97 Bishop c4
this is an excellent position for white
it's very very nice I'm upon up for
pretty much nothing you can try that now
maybe that's some counter play him it
takes remember I can give that even away
i mean this is this is basically
trapping the night so black cannot take
him yeah white is controlling the C file
it has the protected pass 85 is also
hanging yeah c5 is just a strategically
very bad move like should play Bishop d7
here but um yeah the problem was that
this 92 was a very very bad decision and
now my position is is simply
uncoordinated you know the wrong p.m.
black is beginning to to be a quite
substantially better when he got to see
three okay thanks for watching